[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone
nice to see so many people here
i thought i'd talk a bit about the
campaign's free nazis gary radcliffe so
i'm tunis siddique i'm the mp for
hampstead and kilburn i got elected in
2015.
i inherited my seat from i think
inherited i didn't win it but the mp
before me was glenda jackson which many
of you will know
glenda jackson is 85 by the way and
she's back on stage and i speak to her
on the phone quite regularly for anyone
who's interested and she's full of
spirit as she always was swearing and
full of delight about taking down the
government so she's still in good
spirits so i got elected in 2015 in the
most marginal seats in the country after
i got elected i only won by a thousand
votes so fairly marginal seat
i had a baby in 2016 and i'll tell you
why this is relevant
so i had a baby in april on the 8th of
april little girl holds azalea and
believe it or not parliament doesn't
have any maternity leave nothing there's
nothing like you're meant to have a baby
have an emergency c-section like i did
go back to work the next stage that's
what you're meant to do i went back six
weeks later with your doctor's orders
when i was in hospital at the royal free
best hospital in the world in my
constituency
i had a call from my office manager the
day after
and ollie was very apologetic he called
me and he said look i know i'm not meant
to be calling you i know you've had a
dramatic birth but one of your
constituents has been detained in iran
and uh their wife the husband of the of
the person who's been detained has
turned up
to the office saying that they need to
speak to you and this is one of the
things about politics my office manager
is very good very experienced but if i'm
the mp and one of my constituents has
been detained in iran a british citizen
then it doesn't matter if i've just had
a baby or not i've got to deal with this
case
so i said to ali okay well why don't you
send richard the husband of the nazis
zagari radcliff who now has become
famous in his own right to my house i
had no other choice
so the first time i met richard
i was
breastfeeding my newborn i still had my
c-section scars and richard walked in
through the door
i said to him look what's going on and
he said my wife nazineen who is british
but also iranian so she's a british
passport and she's an iranian passport
travelled
she traveled with our 18 month old so
nazney had gone with their 18 month old
to visit her parents in tehran on a
holiday for two weeks
while she was there on the day she was
coming back she was detained at tehran
airport and she was told that she was
charged on
charges of espionage and arrested and
taken to even prison and the daughter
was given the little daughter was given
to the grandparents and i said to
richard right how was all this conveyed
to you and said well the parents told me
and then i went to the foreign office
and the foreign office had said to
richard
don't say anything so that said if you
say anything this will endanger your
wife we might not be able to bring her
back so stay quiet
i said to richard okay then why are you
here if the foreign officer said
don't say anything because if it's gonna
put your wife's life in danger
bear in mind i'd only been an mp for a
year at that point and i was very unsure
about what to do and richard said look
i've stayed quiet now for four weeks
they don't even know where my wife is
they don't know where she is whether
she's an even prison whether she's under
a house arrest they seem just satisfied
with the fact that they know
she's alive but how do they even know
she's alive so i said to richard look
you're making a very big decision here
have you decided that you're going
public with this he said yeah we're
launching a media campaign because
that's the only way to raise attention i
mean it's a very big risk and bear in
mind being a new mp and opposition mp i
really wasn't sure whether this was the
right approach do we go public about the
fact that this woman's been detained do
we um end up
endangering her life does it mean she
never comes back like i wasn't sure
so i rang jeremy corbyn because he was
the leader of labour party at the time
and i said jeremy you know iran well
what should we do about this and he said
okay um
call richard over to your house let's
meet bear in mind again i can't move
from the from my bed following my
emergency c-section so on the defining
moments of my career i have jeremy
corbyn
and richard radcliffe in my living room
with my newborn uh breastfeeding and
taking notes with the other hand on the
iranian revolutionary guards was you
know something i'll always remember so
jeremy's in my living room richard's in
my living room we're like what should we
do about this and
richard said to me there's something
bigger here there's no reason they would
pick up my wife a charity worker keeper
in tehran at this point they haven't
heard anything for six weeks about his
wife
i mean richard is an accountant his wife
is a charity worker and she's been
picked up at the states so he said no
we've got to go public
the minute i went back to parliament we
handed in a petition to david cameron at
the time
and we raised it in in parliament in a
debate the minute her name is gary
radcliffe's name was publicly mentioned
for the first time
in parliament things started moving
philip hammond at the time called us in
for a meeting david kevin received our
petition
the times wrote a little piece about it
and i said to richard look this is
taking off are you sure this is not
endangering your wife's life and you
know i was quite uncertain like i'm not
the foreign secretary i really wasn't
sure what the right approach was he was
absolutely adamant and you know i pay
tribute to this man from west hampton
accountant who said
this is what we've got to do so what
followed is a long series of hunger
strikes and
singing carols handing in petitions
raising it at every opportunity in the
chamber so i raised it with five foreign
secretaries i raised them with three
prime ministers with david cameron with
theresa may with boris johnson
constantly racing and the news to be
fair kept it in the cycle all the time
finally richard got to speak to nazalene
and that was after three months as she
was in solitary confinement when he
spoke to her
he basically said to her is this the
right thing is this the right thing to
be doing going public with the fact that
they've held you
hostage effectively and she said richard
i'm paying the price of a historic debt
and he said what do you mean he said
the country so the uk oduran 400 million
pounds which was a historic debt
dating back to the 1970s where we
purchased some tanks from them and um
they registered some times for us paid
us the money we never gave them the tax
but we never gave the money back that's
basically what happened 400 million
pounds
and richard said to dazny how do you
know that's why you're being held and
she said
the people who are interrogating me told
me they told her from the second week of
her being in prison that the reason she
was being held is not because of
espionage they never said she was guilty
of any crime and this is a reoccurring
theme because i had meetings with the
iranian ambassador as well at no point
did he ever say your constituent is
guilty of this this and this never he
never said she was guilty of anything he
basically said if you give us the money
back you will get your constituent back
so i said to richard i mean this is a
ridiculous situation why has she paid
the price for the money that we as a
country owe iran and he said she's a
pawn caught between the two countries
but she's not the only one
so there were other british nationals
who were captured in iran but their
families had decided
that they weren't going to go public for
fear of endangering their you know
family member i mean i understand that
completely understanding but richard
said to me now we've got to go public on
it so we started raising it more and
more whether it was parliamentary
questions and this is some this is a
campaign where i had to work cross-party
and i know in parliament when normally
when you look at the headlines and you
read the newspapers it's a lot about us
working in silo i mean from the labour
party do i work just with labour party
mps i knew i wasn't going to get
anything done i had to reach across the
political divide no matter what my
differences is so i started talking to
oliver dowden because he had the
conservative mp he had a constituent in
iran as well kamal ferrugi he was
captured there so i said to oliver look
why don't we go together to number 10 to
see theresa may and say look what are we
going to do about getting our
constituents out and actually he agreed
so we went together so this is one of
those things where conservative mp
started working with me because at the
heart of it was real injustice this
woman she'd done nothing wrong we hadn't
paid the price of um this 400 million
pounds and she was in solitary
confinement
separated from her husband separated
from her child and locked up in in even
prison for no reason
lots of things happened during the six
years but we got small victories the
first victory was that she was not
allowed a medical examination she was
going on hunger strike her hair was
falling out she had lumps on her breasts
she wasn't allowed to make medical
examination so richard said to me we've
got to stage basically a protest on this
so we did a massive protest after which
we must have put pressure on the foreign
office who then put pressure on the
iranians and she was allowed in medical
examination so we were like okay it's
obviously worse
the next lobbying that we wanted to do
was to allow her
um phone calls twice a week to her
family in england but also to see her
little daughter who by the way was still
in iran had forgotten how to speak
english and was being raised by her
grandparents speaking farsi
she was then allowed to visit with her
daughter the first time her little
daughter went to see her in prison she
had to put a sack over her head then she
saw her mother and couldn't believe her
mother was alive so it was real human
impact on a small child as well
after that the next thing richard said
to me is that we've got to go i'm going
to go on hunger strike i'll be honest he
asked me to go on hunger strike as well
i said
you're a step too far there but i'll let
you go from just right he went to the
hunger strike we were outside the
iranian embassy they wouldn't open the
door to us but that seemed to have
turned a corner as well after the hunger
strike and i think the foreign office
really realized something was happening
here they called us in they gave us
another update but all the while they
kept saying to us don't make this
campaign public don't talk about nazim
in the press don't talk about this don't
talk about that there's always hush hush
we're doing some mediation behind the
scenes when negotiating with them we'll
bring her back don't say anything
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas